io alla tua età facevo già quattro
lavori Certo sennò come facevo a sfamare
sei figli alla tua età avevo già sei
figli poi gli altri li ho fatti quando
ero più vecchia 23-24 anni Tu quando
pensi di farli l'altro giorno l'ho
incontrata mchina che pena mi ha fatto
Cornuta dalla nascita zia Ora il marito
non lo lascia le piace fare la mantenuta
non mi rispondi neanche ai messaggi io
ti scrivo sempre su WhatsApp non mi
chiami mai mai una volta che rispondi
corso mese mi sono presa un'influenza
fortissima ma tanto di quel muco non
sapevo più dove metterlo quella non è
figlia di Gaetano è figlia di Rosan la
piccila è bionda occhi azzurri e cusi e
Gaetano sono scuri scuri Concettina me
l'ha pure fatto capire m'ha detto quando
Gaetano usciva andava via con la barca
cusi andava un po' troppo spesso in
farmacia non ci sono più le influenze di
una volta eh perché finché si è giovani
come voi ma quando si diventa vecchi si
ha un passo dalla tomba voi giovani
d'oggi siete egoisti Se state male voi
crolla tutto il mondo alla tua età Se
stavo male mi rimbocco sulle maniche
perché L'obiettivo era sempre portare a
casa i soldi per mangiare e tu quand'è
che inizi a lavorare invece